uh this is also the day that uh the mvp
the kia mvp award was handed out to
giannis anada kumpa who got 85 out of
101 first place votes lebron got the
other 16.
he was asked about that after the game
um pissed me off
that's my truly that's my true answer um
it pissed me off because um
out of 101 votes i got 16 first first
place votes
um that's what pissed me off more than
anything
um you know not saying that um you know
the the winner wasn't deserving of the
mvp
um but
that pissed me off um and
i finished second a lot in my in my
career um either from a championship
and now four times as a mvp um
you know like i said i never i never
came into this league saying let me
be mvp or or you know be a champion i've
always said i just want to get better
and better every single day
and those things take care of herself
there's some things that's just out of
my hand and some things you can't
control
but it pissed me off i don't know
how much we are really watching the game
of basketball
or are we just in the
narration mode the narrative
what do you think chuck well i disagree
with him he
people can vote how they want to but
listen it's a regular season award yonas
had
better numbers across the board uh
i'm gonna finish with this last point
number one janice had better numbers
across the board
he had a better record but you know what
the deal is he don't have that dude who
just had 37 tonight
that's to me the big difference so if he
if he's got better numbers
better record but he don't have unto
david the guy
it's really i'm glad he said that
tonight because the guy he played with
tonight
if that guy plays like that the lakers
are going to win the championship
so i don't i don't know first of all he
can have his opinion
but janice was the better player during
the regular season
first of all envy plea mvp player
singular it means individual you all
keep talking about team records and all
that
draymond said it earlier in the world
knows this lebron is the best player in
the world so if you're the best player
in the world can you not be the mvp
okay y'all keep talking about team
records i didn't got nothing to do with
it because i lost twice because
i had a better record but you lost in
the first round i don't want to hear all
that record stuff
you're the best player in the world that
you should always get the mvp period but
if you're the best player in the world
that doesn't always necessarily mean you
had the best season
okay i think giannis had a better season
than lebron but
describe that though okay because what
this
season well i think i mean honestly
janna's had a better season this year
and last year that's fine
but if you're starting a franchise or
you're picking a player to say
go get me a championship you're picking
lebron james which simply tells you that
he's the best player in the world just
because he didn't play
better overall this season which you can
you can argue that he did by the way
but i mean we can talk about the the
records and all of those things don't
matter but if you're
playing the best basketball and you're
leading the team to the most wins
how can i think the narrative does play
a part though yeah i think
you know maybe he shouldn't be 16 maybe
it should be you know
30 32. but the narrative does play a
part
and i think that uh you know when steve
nash
was beating it was the narrative you
know relationships criteria oh he had a
better record but
no no no but i'm something i'm saying
like a lot of times wins and losses
doesn't matter
no your team has to be an mvp of the
league your team should be
one two or three that's just my opinion
um and you were that too
but i'm saying the narrative of doing
something unexpected does
weigh into i think the voters thought
process but they're not mine
all the time but that the voters because
i'm not a voter there's only one guy on
this stage
who's actually a voter and uh oh yeah
and i
voted for giannis right but let me tell
you something when i when i was playing
and i had lebron's second heart and
third when i was
playing how many years you think michael
jordan was the best player
every year you play no no i'm talking
before he won mvps
because his team was no good he was the
better player
way before he started to win mvps he
didn't throw a winning mvp to the bull's
guy
i agree with you and also kobe bryant
was the best player in the league
for x amount of years until the lincoln
start winning again
so it i love this argument every year
it's always went
to the guy with the best record if it
was close
it hasn't changed in 35 years since i've
been around
and we have these silly arguments you
wouldn't would you vote you vote like
that
you would vote like that the record
would mean just as much
yes yeah and jack you would say no it's
an individual ward that's where you're
going you're on the other end
no i'm not saying that but i'm saying if
i got if i got
ernie and i got dick vitell and the
records are close
right dick vittel has a better record i
might have to go to ernie because
ernie's a little bit more dominant
record is cool but that shouldn't be the
only criteria to get you over the top
his team won uh you know 40 games his
team won 39 games so i'm gonna give it
to
you you know and again if it's close
and you know what you know it hurts you
and hurts lebron the expectation yeah
like
we expect 29 12 and 12. that's what i'm
doing
but that's what they expect that's what
we're so good that hurts you how many
years
how many years has it been shaq i'm i'm
just saying it's been a few years first
of all you overrated
i was happy to hear lebron say he was
pissed sure
uh god's life overrated it tell him why
you're mad bro
he's up here hey hey listen if it was
for dwyane wade and kobe bryant you know
we never even heard of you
there's nine rings up here and you ain't
a part of that addiction how about that
yeah lonzo morning too